roughly speaking most of AI programs at
the moment are just these programs which
are heavily optimized in the case of
large language models with unimaginable
amounts of training data an unimaginable
amounts of compute power like 10 to the
23 floating Point operations for for
gpt3 or something which is a number
that's so large it's actually just
meaningless for human beings all
optimized to do a mapping from from the
board position to a move or from a
string to a string in the case of a
large language model and that's all
they're doing they're simply heavily
optimized to do that does meaning and
understanding emerge out of that and
when will we know when we've done it our
large language models part of the
ingredient for AI for the larger vision
of AI which Gary is very passionate
about and I've grown up with and the
jury is out I think I mean they are
certainly interesting but whether they
are going to lead to understanding in
any meaningful sense I think is the
jury's very much out